ja sie haben es ja gerade gehört eine
betroffene frau bellers sie hat sich am
samstag testen lassen also fast eine
woche her hat immer noch nicht ergebnis
und es laufen auch nach 150 positiv
getestete menschen in bayern rum die
nichts davon wissen wer ist dieses
versagen zu erklären zunächst ist es
wirklich sehr ärgerlich dass diese panne
passiert ist weil frau wird mich
interessieren ob sie aus einem
risikogebiet eingereist ist oder nicht
wenn sie mehr aus einem risikogebiet
gekommen ist dann muss ich ja sowieso
für zehn tage quarantäne
das heißt da wird dann auch keine
weiteren personen infiziert und da gibt
es dann auch deshalb keine großen
probleme
sie müssen auch wissen dass wir in
bayern diesen kostenlosen service den
wir anbieten
für die anderen bundesländer mit
anbieten 60 prozent der getesteten
kommen nicht aus bayern
dh von diesen 100 mal nach meinen zahlen
100 positiv getestet die ergebnis noch
nicht haben sind etwa 60 prozent zu 60
leute außerhalb bayerns und die andere
länder testen ja anders als bei nicht
das heißt insofern ist es dasselbe wenn
jetzt die ergebnisse nicht mehr
vorliegen könnten und sollten wie die
anderen bundesländer die überhaupt nicht
testen das ist zwar hoch bedauerlich
weil wir wirklich die gesundheit und das
leben der menschen in den mittelpunkt
stellen und je besser sein wollten
das bei einem relativ kleinen teil jetzt
nicht geklappt hat leider gottes
deswegen kann man diesen menschen nur
raten doch noch mal selber zum hausarzt
zu gehen und sich selber noch mal testen
zu lassen wenn sie wirklich bis zum
wochenende kein ergebnis bekommen
sollten